good morning John so here's the thing
that I don't think nerdfighters need to
be told maybe you know subconsciously
even if you don't think about it because
I don't really think about it that often
but it's definitely a choice I make
every single video somebody is in it
because I want as many people as
possible to see them whether that's just
to get a lot of views because it feels
good or to grow the community or to
convey an idea that I feel like more
people need to have in their head and
some videos are just for nerdfighters
just for the people who were gonna watch
no matter what as long as I don't just
sit here and do nothing for four minutes
and I gotta say I really like those
videos it's like not having the pressure
I like just being able to talk about
what's in my head also this community
has given me so many wonderful gifts I
like to give you guys gifts back I'll do
a lot of things for you guys do you want
to see me like a battery ah ah I
connected the positive and the negative
science probably not it's weird to feel
in debt to a lot of people and not know
how to pay that debt back one of the
ways I feel like I can do it is just to
make videos for you that nobody else is
gonna see and it's clearly just for the
people who have been so supportive of us
also I feel like it's good to like
define what the community of
nerdfighteria is every once in a while
because I think some people don't really
understand I mean I don't think that
anybody really understands but I didn't
just get an ask from somebody on tumblr
who said that they've been shamed in a
nerdfighter community for being
transgender and like what I don't know
how someone could feel like that's the
kind of thing that a nerdfighter would
do but it's not that's your that's not a
nerd thats not a nerdfighter
so sometimes I worry about what this all
is and that people are doing the wrong
things in the name of the thing and not
understanding the thing and I also worry
about the decoupling of productivity in
wages productivity is just all of the
benefits to humans that the economy
creates and wages of course are the
money that people make and they used to
be two things that were really closely
tied together and now they're not
anymore I'm worried about what this
means for our society that the rich are
just gonna get richer and the poor
aren't gonna benefit it's gonna create
instability as well as suffering I'm
also interested in what the world's
gonna look like if we're able to create
lots of cool services for people and
they're gonna be so cheap that maybe
people don't even need to pay for them
like what does that will look like I
want to make a video on this topic video
that lots of people not just
nerdfighters would watch but I'm no
economists oh I got to do a bunch of
research and learn stuff like like how
to pronounce
economists also VidCon is coming up I'm
not worried about VidCon in general
there's lots of cool things that are
like amazing things they're gonna happen
if it kinda it's gonna be a good time
but we're having this meet and greet
lottery thing if you want to go to into
the signing hall and get any signings or
pictures anything you got to do the
lottery you got a rank all your favorite
creators how much you like them and then
the system assigns you meet and greets
and if you don't do the lottery thing
you don't get any and so far only about
half of people who have registered have
signed up for the lottery and that
terrifies me because I feel like maybe
they just don't know it's a thing maybe
I'm living in this old person world
where people check their email and they
don't check their email and I don't know
how to get in touch with people who
don't check their email I'm worried
about people showing up at VidCon being
very disappointed because they did not
sign up for the lottery but I don't know
what to do about that problem so those
are some things I've been worrying about
here's some things that I'm excited
about let's produce multiple YouTube
shows and what producing means I'm not
really sure one of those shows is called
how to adult which is fairly
self-explanatory and it's very useful
even for me a guy who's been adulting
for like 15 years how to adult is
launching its patreon page today to help
pay for its existence so if you are
interested in learning how to adult or
you already like how to adult and you
want to help them continue making cool
stuff you can check that stuff out
there's links in the description I'm
also producing a new show with Charlie
McDonnell called cereal time it's a
morning show 5 days a week it's a lot
like good mythical morning but it's more
British I'm excited about doing more
things with nerdfighteria who would
stuff together like I wanted to ask a
Ventura haunt so I'm gonna be thinking
about that and maybe you can help but
I'm not gonna tell you how to help cuz I
already did thank you to all the people
who watch this video because I know that
you are among the people who watch them
no matter what every single one and that
means a lot to me thanks for being a
part of this John I'll see you on
Tuesday
[Music]